if you leave that digital marketing team
you know what's hard to stay ahead of
the curve the technology and techniques
are constantly changing your team is
running in all directions making it hard
to collaborate on innovative marketing
and missions you look at your
competition and say how can we do that
well watch or simply learn comes in
simply one has created a robust digital
marketing curriculum
purpose-built for the digital enterprise
of today and tomorrow
we provide best of class digital
marketing training we cover all eight
essential disciplines of digital
marketing search and pay-per-click
advertising search engine optimization
social media email display and
programmatic by mobile marketing web
analytics and conversion optimization
our blended online an instructor-led
training model allows participants
around the globe simultaneous access to
a sample class content with courses
developed by industry experts hello
everybody my name is Danny Dover I am
the former lead SEO at ATT former lead
SEO at a company called SEO Maz I wrote
a best-selling book called SEO secrets
and really I'm just a nerd about this
SEO stuff my name is Tiffany mill I'm a
digital analyst I'm a consultant a
teacher speaker will simply learn
employees can interact directly with
faculty and collaborate with each other
to get answers and work together now as
for team leaders our learning management
system lets you track your team's daily
progress and measure the success its our
unique outcome oriented approach that is
led companies like Microsoft Ford
Proctor gammon Olga V to trust us for
their digital marketing corporate
training so contact us and find out how
simply learnt industry-leading training
can turn your digital marketing
investment into a source of competitive
advantage
simply learn learn to win